call of duty black ops and modern
warfare two
very different ends of the same call of
duty spectrum
but how does 2020's offering hold up
does it build
upon modern warfare's idea of more
casual play
introducing battle royales and strange
seasons of peculiar weapons well joining
me today
is richie bracamonte we're gonna figure
out which call of duty
is right for you
[Music]
all right richie you're a pro gamer tell
me your feels
about the multiplayer offerings for both
these games starting with modern warfare
i had a great time
a wonderful time with 2019's modern
warfare and uh
around the office we all agree that it
took a lot of risks even for call of
duty players who were comfortable where
they were
a lot of things like the very big map
design which was uh
some would say very they they called it
very porous and i agree with that
totally
but it was built that way so that it was
approachable to everyone
uh in terms of camping and hiding so it
was a little more rewarded in this game
yeah talking about maps i i fully agree
with you one of my favorite additions
to modern warfare was ground war i'm a
huge battlefield fan
so having basically call of duty
battlefield that was like kind of their
offering was a really welcome addition
and it made it feel
like a much more accessible game on pc
as well
and i don't think groundwater got as
much love as i wanted
it to have but i was really impressed
with how
they were able to balance vehicles huge
maps
huge number of players when it isn't
really
call of duty's forte with with that idea
in mind i think
they really knocked out the park and for
all the time i played modern warfare
2019 that was easily my most
played game mode when it comes to black
ops however though i am really enjoying
the multiplayer it does
for me at least feel like a more arcadey
experience than modern warfare did the
maps
are a lot tighter they
a lot of them stick to the classic call
of duty three lane
sort of thing i just don't i haven't
really gelled with the rhythm
of the game yet
maybe it's because the fire team is in
that middle ground of the the arcade
team deathmatch stuff and then the
groundwall really objective based stuff
that i'm used to
it's kind of fireteam's not quite found
a home yet
i've played the dirty bomb mode as well
and as i think
we both agree on really cool concept
little messy
but it's it's an environment that you
don't have to take
too seriously totally it's it's a
it's again another really good idea on
paper a little chaotic
and if you're not playing with friends
it's slightly worse
randoms like kind of go off and do their
own thing more than ever in this mode
and don't play the objective at least at
launch but yeah it's
it's cool because it's mixing ideas from
even like warzone and modern warfare
with arm plate system and uh big team
objectives so
i welcome it but i'm with you with uh
the overall
gelling of the overall feeling of this
game it's coming from modern warfare
it's kind of a
it feels like a step backwards
technically a step backwards but just
where they've already been if that makes
sense
warfare was a jump forward and now black
ops it feels like
they've gone back to familiar ground
with that sort of really very fast-paced
uh arcadey style um yeah
i i see why me personally and as you've
said it's it's
finding it hard to get into the rhythm
but part of me is also concerned that
maybe modern warfare just spoiled us
with with loads of maps towards the end
of its
well before black ops came out loads of
guns switching to this now i i
feel like uh hey where's the rest of it
i'm i'm still hungry
like where's the rest of my meal
well that was the multiplayer offerings
but i am someone who does not sleep
on a good call of duty campaign and
thankfully 2019
and 2020's black ops have both been
great
campaigns but as far as i'm concerned
2019
really set a bar for call of duty
campaigns
and not just because it pulled at your
nostalgia with bringing back
mustachio himself captain price although
that is a huge part of it
captain price sergeant garrick you're
with me
might be the wrong thing to say but
2019's call of duty it felt like they
gave a [ __ ] about campaigns again
and that created a really tight
interesting exciting
cinematic experience that call of duty
used to be known for
overall it was a successful
like reimagining or reintroduction of
the modern warfare series because it's
not always easy to do a reboot in fact
it's probably really hard
they put it they they explained that
like we have to make your memories of
this story of the modern warfare story
as good as ever even better so and i
think they did a really good job with
that
yeah for sure um and they made some
really interesting and sometimes
controversial choices
the london raid mission was a really i
mean it was a great mission it was
really exciting to play and i could see
why there were people that had issues
with it and you know
activision themselves calls the player
out if you are some kind of
sick weirdo who wants to try and shoot
the baby in the mission talking about
black ops single player now i think
black ops cold war might be one of my
favorite campaigns
it nails the kind of pulp 80s movie vibe
that i think it was going for it was a
little
like kind of man from uncle meets james
bond
meets the the call of duty black ops
story that we know
adding in really interesting locations
really interesting mechanics
it's also just good to see familiar
faces again in a
down to earth as down to earth as you
can get with espionage
storyline but you know we're not in the
future anymore we're back in 81
and it's it's looking like it's looking
solid and since i saw the ending
i can say that it's nice to see that you
have some options along the way
the whole structure of the campaign was
really well done i think
having those sort of side missions that
you actually had to think about
one example is you're trying to decipher
like
cryptographs and pass codes and hidden
messages
and listen to number stations and you're
actually having to do it yourself you're
solving
the little hidden russian secrets within
newspapers and radio waves
if you manage to figure it out and get
the the results you want and then finish
the game
it has that kind of fallout thing
when when ron perlman would be like and
the
character did this and this and it would
be reflected in your
choices you made and if you were a
clever clogged and figured out
and that i was like that's
so very cool and so very stylish
it's it's like refreshing that there's
for once replayability
in a call of duty game you know you do
the campaign
at the end of the year when the game
comes out every year and then you you
don't really think about it too much
anymore
but they've implemented all these side
puzzles and alternate endings and
if you do specific things in the
campaign i've noticed that uh you get
these challenges unlocked that give you
banners for multiplayer you know
cosmetics for uh your emblems and stuff
like that like
it it's worth going back to i can't
recommend the black ops cold war
campaign enough i see people
it happens every year with call of duty
that's why
call of duty's in the past didn't have a
campaign because people weren't playing
them
stop playing half your game you paid for
the campaign
play the damn thing
so the two games co-op offerings are
very
different on one end we have
spec ops which was a little
disappointing i'm not afraid to say
and zombies which seems to get more
bombastic and strange peculiar
every year but why don't we start off
with spec ops
and i appreciate the effort that went in
to making this but i don't think
it was really what people wanted or what
they were expecting
i agree it was it was pretty broken at
launch um again the idea was cool
of a pve mode that extends
the great story the great campaign um
and you know you can find
intel along the way it sounded like a
cool idea on paper but it was kind of
it was actually very rough at launch and
it took a while for a
solid patch to get things going decently
uh the enemies were way too crazy
way too uh difficult there were way too
many
it felt like you weren't going anywhere
unless you had a team that knew exactly
what they were doing
every mission which you know he grinded
out like i did i finished all the spec
op missions you know
at what cost but by the end it was
finally playable
and i get what they were doing it was it
was it was just rough
but personally when i heard spec ops was
coming back i
just remembered modern warfare 2. one of
warfare 2's spec ops modes when you had
the series of missions that were little
stories that were really
well done and tightly packed if i
thought they were going to do something
like that again and
you know when we get another modern
warfare entry i hope
that's how they do spec ops because
getting one of your friends and playing
through those
was so good dropping us all in a random
map
and just yeah shooting bullet sponge
enemies
was not it chief
that's a bit [ __ ] but it couldn't be
more different for the co-op offerings
of
black ops cold war and zombies are back
much like the
campaign the zombies mode was kind of
brought back down to earth
and uh it's still a very fantastical
story but we're starting from like
a new plot line that's just also
approachable
and it's it's a it's a great map it's
approachable but it's familiar because
uh
it's the it's based off of the very
first map that ever existed for zombies
back for
nazi zombies and world at war and that's
there it is that's the one um i did not
want to butcher that so thank you
it's a beautifully upgraded map now that
takes place in the 80s
there's a big lab and the easter egg
is i would say like medium level
difficulty so you can do it and now you
have now you have the option to do it
solo which is nice
in black ops 4 there were so many perks
and things you can equip
to make your character better and
they've kind of scaled that back down to
familiar perks and i think it's a lot
more playable for people who haven't
played before and
um comfortable for people who have for
me this
entry of zombies has just been like this
is meant to be a silly fun mode
with a little challenge to it it's that
again
and i honestly couldn't be happier with
zombies
thank you thank you blessed zombie god
for returning to us
well which call of duty is going to be
right for you then if you've somehow
not played either personally i think if
you're after
a more visceral experience if you want
the larger maps if like me you're a
lapsed
battlefield fan that's still got some of
that itch that needs scratching
then 2019's modern warfare still has
loads to offer you if you want something
that's
more stylistic more arcadey more
jump in play a few rounds enjoy the
speed and
action cinematics of it then i think
you're going to have
more enjoyment with black ops cold war
what do you think richie i'm in the same
boat i really loved what call of duty
did
in 2019 and the whole year was great
they did a lot of things right
although it was a departure from classic
call of duty style of games in terms of
multiplayer
uh black ops cold war it's a little
early to tell us i'm doing the juggling
act right now
you know but uh i am enjoying my time
with it hopefully
as the year goes on we'll see more
improvements in patches because you know
we can live in a world with
both of these titles and be just fine
they don't have to be the same game
so i'm looking forward to seeing what'll
come exactly we're in a position now
where
there's a share world within warzone
there's
cross play everywhere and i think both
games have something to offer and
there's a unifying thing with both games
i think
and that is that no matter what you play
no matter what system you play on
you're going to have to do a big ass
install
i think i think i think that's quite
beautiful but they that they share that
i think that's really hits me where i
live
but to see where else i live you can
subscribe to gamespot
hope you enjoyed this video like if you
did let us know your thoughts in the
comment section below which call of duty
you're playing this season
and if i see anyone sink my boat
on that weird black ops boat map we're
gonna fall out
all right we'll see you next time
you